[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody
how's the day going HTP help we have to
do diagram he'll stay going HTTP headers
for the responsible developer let me
tell you about my journey on the web so
it was one of these lucky people that
had already an internet connection at
home very early because my father was a
text every person but actually in the
beginning I had no idea what I should do
with this Internet right I could Google
a stuff but that was basically it then I
was whatever twelve years old and it was
not that exciting but then I discovered
this website vote.com
any Germans around that that was one of
the first social networks in Germany and
there was 1999 and this is where I'm
coming from the middle of nowhere north
of Germany and I thought myself chatting
to people in Berlin mainly about music
and this is when I found out for the
first time that the web actually
connects people it's not about googling
stuff it's about connecting people then
I moved to Berlin and I had a different
job initially and 2010 something
interesting happened I became a web
developer which is cool but then the
statement that the web connects people
actually changed we as developers have a
lot of power and I one of the sleeps 1%
believe that we connect now people
because rebuilding stuff for the
Internet we enabled people and we help
people buy the stuff that we built so
let me quickly introduce myself hey i'm
stefan i work for a company called
Twilio we do communications as an api so
if you want to do SMS what's that phone
calls and all these kind of things you
can check that out and the most
important thing is that hey i'm stefan
and i want to be a responsible developer
so when we look at the global population
you will find out that 1999 they are
worse and my little bubble north of
germany not much going on but we're
actually the most Internet users are
coming from today so they're coming from
China India and the United States but
is just global statistics right but I
also do run a private blog and only the
last month I had 300 people from Brazil
reading my articles at 100 people from
Vietnam and at 80 people from South
Africa that gets really exciting right
Who am I I'm writing stuff on people and
Brazil are reading my stuff but at the
end that really doesn't matter because
we as web developers should be building
for everybody and responsive web design
came up I heard this statement way too
often we don't have users coming from a
certain area we don't have users that
use a certain device when you say these
kind of statements what you're actually
doing is you're creating it's shaking in
that problem when you don't build stuff
that works for people under certain
conditions these people won't use your
stuff but building a good website these
days is actually very very hard because
what you have to do you have to consider
design colors around the world are
different you have to bring up good
content you have to consider web
performance which is a big topic by
itself you have to make yourself
accessible because there may be people
that visit your sites with assistive
technology you have to find out what
should I use actually frameworks words
are a thing right weird reskin fear you
have to optimize the network stack and
you have to make it work on several
devices and there are many many more
factors out there and in the next 21
minutes I want to talk about the network
stack so let's talk about HTTP so
basically when your browser makes a
request through a resource what it does
it sends you a set of key value pairs
these are called request headers and
then the server responds with a tunnel
with another set of key value pairs and
the actual resource that you're asking
for so we're dealing with response and
request headers and when I started
probation for this talk dot then dot def
domains were actually trending so I had
to buy it def domain so here you see the
responsible def and this is site but it
has right now javascript disabled so
what you see here when i refresh it
there are some stuff going on
first of all the script is hijacking
adding it unicorns and stuff but also
when you go to coat pan for example you
can just frame this side and you can
pretend to be my site you could click
check and track what people are doing
pretending to be my unicorn not unique
on site my responsible deaf side so what
I wanted to do is that I wanted to make
this site better by just using headers
and to serve the whole topic is that the
web is a scary place a few months ago
this was kind of in the news lots of
websites were mining cryptocurrency and
the developers that built these sites
didn't even know about this and the
reason for that is that when we're
building for the web is that we're
always relying on other people building
software open source of the thing right
and we also load third parties from
different domains so we always rely on
others and I believe that the web has to
be safe the biggest part of being safe
is HTTPS so without HTTPS what is
possible is that someone can open up a
public Wi-Fi and when you're browsing
with HTTP this person could pretend to
be the Wi-Fi and could interfere all the
requests and just mess with you or get
all the passwords that you're typing and
sending through over HTTP but also HTTPS
and iOS you to use cutting-edge features
like HTTP to service workers and get
using media and I in my front-end bubble
I think that HTTP is already a standard
but for example there's the site out
there that is called why no HTTP and if
there's many many sites that are not
enforcing HTTPS yet and when you look
when you go onto this list we found out
that our ID that's massive German media
outlet it's not enforcing HTTPS which is
very very surprising so when you run
then on HTTPS what you want to do is
that you maybe want to ensure that it is
always HTTPS and on a secure connection
so what you can do is you can set the
strict Transport Security header which
you can define a max age property in
seconds this will tell the browser hey
please only use this website or this
resources over HTTPS you can define how
wide it should range and you can if you
want to be a go the extra mile you can
define a preload directive which
basically allow
you to submit your site to another site
which is called HSTs preload and the
thing about that is that browsers
internally keep a list of websites that
should only run on HTTPS this is the
configuration file that is included in
chromium this is just massive array
including thousands of sites that will
never work on HTTP in case you wonder
why dot def domains are not possible to
use HTTP anymore that's the reason dot F
is inside of this file but HSCs is not
only about security what happens when
you type something in the address bar of
your browser the browser will make an
HTTP request initially which when you're
on a slow connection could lead to a
delay of three four five seconds
depending on the connection which HSTs
you can skip this request because the
browser knows we're going HTTP that's it
so that's the support for HSTs we're
pretty green here which is pretty sweet
but I'm forcing HTTPS is not the easiest
thing in the world when you're dealing
with big projects where a lot of people
are basically putting a lot of source
code in your in your codebase so how do
you tackle this approach to go to over
HTTPS when you run your site over HTTPS
and you make a request to an HTTP versus
may be blocked by the browser so what
you can do is you can set a content
security policy header with the upgrade
insecure with Chris directive and this
magically updates all the requests to be
HTTPS and secure that is super cool but
this is not the main purpose of CSP the
main purpose of CSP is that you want to
limit what is allowed inside of your
websites and you can configure a lot of
things so this is a complete list of
what is possible with CSP you can define
where should fronts be loaded from where
should images be loaded from and there
are a few cutting edge things in there
like this on opener navigates you and I
think that's very exciting because you
basically can trim down what is allowed
in your website and you can avoid mining
cryptocurrency in your website because a
third party got hacked you can use CSP
with a major element in your HTML or you
set a header like this
this is the header that I ship for my
private website and includes all the
third parties that I have and coming up
with this is actually very very hard I
deployed CSP three times and broke my
site and rolled back so what you want to
do is you want to set a different header
which is report only which then allows
you to define an HTTP endpoint and then
you get all the warnings of requests
that which would be blocked if this
would be active and you can start
monitoring what is going on when you lot
watch this when you have a detailed look
at this rule set you will find out that
there is something not that right
I have unsafe inline and unsafe evil
right now in there and it bothers me but
I'm using a JavaScript framework that in
lines JavaScript Jason in the body so
that the JavaScript front-end framework
gets the state and I'm fixing it I'm
working on fixing that that's not the
easy thing when you're dealing with a
framework the way that this should work
is that inline scripts when you have CSP
enabled you have two ways you can either
define a hashed value in his CSP
directive so that you can say hey this
hashed value should be allowed in my
website this is a little bit brittle
though because now when you update your
contents of the script then you have to
change this header or your meta element
in the head what you can also do is you
can define a nonce value which is
basically giving an ID and you can say
hey yeah this this part is cool please
allow this so also support for CSP CSP
is out there in two levels level one
allgreen pretty cool cutting-edge stuff
and more fancy stuff is a little bit
jumpy still and M I think's missing but
you can have a look about that that so I
think this technology is actually very
exciting because it makes the web a
safer place but how many pages actually
use CSP so there's this website out
there that is called HTTP archive org
which crawls the internet and then you
can write search queries and when you do
that you will find out that only 6% of
the internet or if the crawled websites
use CSP this is surprisingly low and I
think we can do better so when you want
to start
working with CSP start in report mode
monitor what is coming in and out don't
break your sight and then when you only
when you are safe and you know that all
your requests resources are whitelisted
then you can turn it on so for my
responsible deaf side what I did is I
added a new route which is slash safe
and I set some headers so first of all
you see that the unicorns are gone
because the requests that went there is
not allowed Chrome is also reporting me
that I'm using something that is not
reported yet but also when I now go to
code pad and go to the framing site
chrome will say hey this is not allowed
for this site so people can not hijack
my stuff which is pretty cool because
this makes my site safer and this is
very very important because the web is
crucial for people I travel quite a
little bit and what happens when for
example I go to I wasn't the Ukraine
Ukraine and two months ago so I get out
of a plane and I get this SMS messages
by my mobile provider and basically
tells me this and just because this is
ridiculous I get two six megabytes for
two euros but I have to use in 24 hours
this doesn't even hold me 30 minutes the
web has to be affordable and this is a
crucial piece for us building a gun
internet so one thing that we have to do
there is that don't request the same
content over and over and over again and
what you can do to avoid that is you can
set proper caching headers caching is
very very tricky and I'm only going
briefly into it so I'm defining there
that in seconds a max edge property and
telling hey this is holding how long
this resource could be potentially
cached but this doesn't necessarily mean
that there are no requests flying
because browser also revalidate if the
resource is changed so what is cool that
is you can also define a mutable
directive which then tells the browser
hey this is maybe a hashed value like
Stiles hash dot CSS ojs or something and
the browser will never requested it
again it will not revalidate stuff I
think that's very cool because this way
you can save some requests unfortunately
the support from immutable is not that
great anymore because it was supported
and etch but
now switch to chromium so if you want to
learn more about caching I can highly
recommend to check out this article by
Harry Roberts it goes over all the
directives and if you want to learn how
to set propagation control headers and
you can check this out it's not only
about requests though it's also about
sending the right data so what happens
when your browser requests some HTML
what it does is it sends some a header
that is called accept-encoding and it
tells the server hey this is what I
understand cool and you see that gzip
deflate and portly and portly is a
different compression algorithm and what
you see there is that I took a CSS file
and I compress it with a two different
compression algorithms so you see that
totally by itself is a little bit
smaller than gzip but surprisingly
people are not using that very often
because what the whole industry thinks
is that politically compression is so
slow it's so hard to encode so when you
use gzip usually what happens is that
the server automatically compresses it
on the fly and makes a gzip with prote
Lee it may be a little bit slow but when
you will say this sentence what you're
basically doing is that you're comparing
apples with oranges so let's have a look
at how gzip importantly works Jesus
basically has nine modes that it can run
in portly has 11 when you use these in
default mode gzip runs in level six and
Portland Branson level 11 the thing that
was that level 6 in gzip is there to be
optimized for speed and compression
ratio the broadly default mode is there
only to save the most amount of file
size so when you tweak totally a little
bit and you go not where the default
mode but rather with level 4 it tends to
compress better where the same speed on
the fly you can set this and save some
bytes on the wire but maybe you have a
build process in place and maybe you
don't even want to compress it on the
fly because you have a build process in
place right
you could compress all your files were
brought in and statically serve them to
save some kilobytes if you want to learn
more about these this topic the
difference from Akamai did extensive
research about what this means so what's
the support of Hoadley
pretty there all the big sites like
Facebook Dropbox they are shipping
broadly nice I would hope that we do
more things with this that's not only
about compression it's also about
serving tailored media because images
are mainly the thing that costs the most
amount of data on the web so and when
you do when you're doing front-end and
you want to ship for example an image
format that is called web P which tends
to be a little bit smaller than JPEG you
find yourself building things like this
this is a picture element responsive
images for several sizes and it also
ships repeat when the browser
understands it this is horrible
right you do feature detection this will
break when the next person comes in but
get one guess what the browser also
tells the server what image formats is
there in a sense so what you could do
potentially for browsers that support
web P is that you could read this header
and you can surf and web pmh instead of
a JPEG when the browser tells you that
this works but you can't go even further
when someone requests your website and
you set for example they accept CH
header this stands for client side you
can tell the browser hey I would like to
know how wide your viewport is and
please tell it to me for the next 100
seconds what happens then
for the additional image requests is
that the browser will tell you
dimensions of the images I mean how cool
is that
this means that you can use normal
images without all the responsive images
stuff but you have to give it a sizes
attribute and so that the browser
upfront knows how these images layout
and this is then the request that goes
out it will tell viewport width and
width of their image and guess what when
you're on a high density then the high
pixel resolution display it will tell
you the real size of the image you can
then serve proper images we are
server-side generation or serviceworker
which is pretty pretty cool I'm very
excited about this this is a little bit
cutting edge though if you want to learn
more about client hints what you can do
is you can check out this resource by
Jeremy Ragna he does a lot of cool
things around this topic so I tweaked to
another side of my responsible dev
science you see there slash affordable
so what you see there that is that I'm
shipping broadly
and you see there also that the image
element is a JPEG but I'm serving web P
without any markup changes and it tells
me how big the image is and when I now
change the viewport you will see that
the image will get smaller because the
server knows what resources I should
ship and what image would be the perfect
fit here so the web has to be affordable
because the web is with us every day
unfortunately we reached this state in
the web right now it's not playing here
we go
this is maybe a former colleague of mine
this is where we are right we are web
developers this is what we built I
believe that the web has to be
respectful and the one of the most
things that we should honor more is time
and we should get the stuff that we
shipped down more quickly so what you
can do is you can optimize the loading
process for certain things and you can
use link rel preload in your HTML or you
can set a header which then gives some
information to this to the browser
telling hey
you will need this resources please
start loading it because the person
maybe don't want it doesn't want to load
wait for a phone to kick in and watch
the blank screen when you lose use the
HTTP header you have to be a little bit
careful though when you're using certain
proxy servers or CDNs link rel preload
will lead to a server push command which
is then not taking the a browser cache
of the into consideration so if you use
this header you have to use no push this
is great to speed up critical resources
so how is the support today for link rel
preload that's pretty good so you can
start adding these kind of things and
optimize the loading process to maybe
get your fonts or header images down
quicker and optimized for the time of
your visitors the next thing is I want
to talk about is the amp reaction so
two-and-a-half years ago I was giving a
talk about amp and how it works
technically actually it's very
interesting what they do and when amp
was released your voice he does a lot of
stem standard work and spec writing and
in the weapon ecosystem what he did is
when he saw that we need to come up with
an alternative very very quickly because
amp is very JavaScript driven and that
is very cool because now two years later
what is slowly coming is the future
policy header so what you can do there
is you can define what should be allowed
in your website and there's a lot of
cool stuff and possible that you can
configure should it be possible that a
third-party script coming from somewhere
accesses wants to access my camera I
think this is cool that you can block a
lot of things that should be possible by
default unfortunately we're now entering
a little bit of cutting edge technology
here but they're also very cool things
and they're like and
itemized media and answers media and
optimized images this way you can limit
yourself and can tell the browser I
don't want to ship even accidentally
massive images you can then also define
this for iframes and there will be a
JavaScript it's already shipping in
chromium browsers there's also a
JavaScript API that lets you access
these values that came in via header the
JavaScript API is still under
discussions also please use that very
carefully so if you had a look at this
list very carefully you might have
noticed that there was one thing missing
in this huge list of things that you
don't want to allow on your site what's
the most annoying one in websites these
days fortunately vacations right people
working on these kind of things figured
out that handling push notifications and
disallowing them is a little bit
trickier than first thought
so if you want to learn more about how
we go with these kind of things you can
follow this issue so what's the support
for feature policy bad which is pretty
pretty cool so with these kind of
headers I set up another side which was
slash respectful and what you see there
is that the permission dialog is gone
because I don't allow it and then also
the J's convey you PNG which is in the
Bowden and defined in CSS I pushed that
to be loaded quicker which makes maybe
the experience a little bit better so
building for the web is very very very
hard these days there are so many things
to consider you have to think about the
design the content web performance
accessibility frameworks network and
devices and there's surely more things
that you have to consider when you're
building for the web so all things
headers this 20 minutes rundown was it's
not a complete one if you want to get a
complete overview my friend Shep
maintains this slight egg this is a
massive resource if you want to know
what HTTP headers are out there and also
you can also just Google headers for
hackers
so Andrew Betts also gives this
fantastic talk if you want to learn more
so I really believe that the web has to
be safe it shouldn't be possible that my
mother browsers the web and mines
cryptocurrency that should be possible
there has to be affordable because
people pay a different amount of money
pending on which situation there aren't
where they are in the world and it has
to be respectful respectful because
nobody likes a person that is asking
random questions and permissions all the
time so the web has to be safe
affordable and respectful so that it
really is for everybody thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]